what if I told you you can literally eat
fire yes literally in India pan is a
huge culinary darling that's been around
for centuries
it's a snack usually eaten after a meal
to help with digestion it consists of a
betel leaf that's wrapped around all
kinds of different fillings like nuts
fennel cardamom fruits chocolate or even
meat you can find it anywhere but a
small street food shack in New Delhi is
sparking a revolution
hello you big horrible thing
it's all throughout on 1950 sequel
America's young people a softlock Aditi
Easter memory past Panama flavours niche
Aparna jihad upon chocolate fun but I
squash pawn through tenet fun black
currant bun stove reap on with me jo
aapko pasando Gallego co e flavor
delicate or exam factor accuse Camus
medallion
alright then but back to the revolution
is sparking recently he had an idea that
would reignite the classic Indian snack
his Shack was famous for starting man
glutamic la vie a long me like I can
look at this OCP a legato
jalaja oh it's calculated nothing so
here is where logo is called your kids
who've YouTube or whatsapp play darling
like it if given essay is calculated in
14 Bob Saget I have a burning question
for you is it safe to eat boy
side-effect Nia the carne or Leticia van
Gogh Sakuraba Jana giveth it though the
eyes open they are confided Hospital
davara Oviatt eNOS a tamale Jackie
apneic a hugger
Avni parousia Sachiko Villa Gesell Java
- killer ow
the pilot oven glove compartment
da-da-da-da-da begin a beacon is a
clever girl [ __ ]
honey you're really bringing on the heat
okay that was a slow burner I was just
warming up
okay okay we've already burned too much
time subsided apart Bonnie look honey
urban legend Anupam Kher Tosca audio
resultant arduous Calgary Tom McCarthy
it never calm I got a new dolly this is
ganguro Tommy hey or I'm a surrogate so
there you have it
India's hottest trend
[Music]